yo what is up guys we're back alright so
this video might get a lot of hate am I
not but I want you guys to know right
before this video start I am not
investing into any of the items I'm
gonna be talking about in this video
yeah I just wanted to settle that before
the video started anyways we're back
this is gonna be the top 5 item you
should invest in or the next big quest
coming out Dragon Slayer 2 now back in
November this quest was actually
announced by the dev team there was a
hold of blog on it so they talked about
requirements they talked about how the
quest was gonna roll out they even
talked about the rune dragons and the
adamant dragons so nothing is actually
new this is a month old news and it
isn't very difficult to predict which
items are obviously gonna shoot up in
price because the demand is gonna be
insane when the quest comes out and this
is a huge question we all remember the
first dragon slayer as a nostalgic f2p
quest and a part two that that is even
more epic so people are gonna be hyped
people are gonna be going in the GE
they're gonna be getting gear that they
see on Bodie stream and they're gonna be
upset because it's all gonna be
skyrocketed in price and people are
gonna be confused people are gonna panic
people are gonna panic by item and I'm
basically here to pretty much inform you
on which items you should buy before
that all happened now what made my life
much easier when picking these items was
looking at the GE grab since the quest
is being released very soon I'm talking
about like a month Mac some of these
items have already gone up in price
which has made picking the items for
this list much much easier but yeah the
first thing we're gonna do guys to start
with a very very basic one this is one
that I instantly thought of something
you actually need to kill the new
monsters the adamant and rune dragons
which are basically anti fire potions or
extended anti fire potions basically
anything with the [__] name anti fire
in it is going to shoot up in price a
lot I'm just gonna show you guys some GE
tracker graphs of these items that I'm
talking about if you want to check out
the website a link is gonna be in the
description as you guys can see when the
dev blog came out about Dragon Slayer 2
they were hovering around 600 GP and in
the past month they have almost doubled
in price right now they're sitting at
around 800 GP I imagine how much they'll
be when the quest comes out now extended
anti fires are the exact same deal guys
about November 16th they were 463 and
now they're going for 600 to 700 GP anti
fires are definitely a safe investment
in every
one's gonna need them on the day release
you can only buy 2,000 of them a day so
get your ass on it boys alright on to
the second item guys the dragon fire
shield now this item has had a very
heavy drop in the past months a lot of
shields have been coming out that are
just holy Tinley better and the dragon
defender is just like a free dragon fire
shield oh yeah guys we're gonna look at
the graph and know what happened here in
November loved they were six point nine
mil I wonder what happened there guys oh
wait Dragon Slayer - is it out and how
much are they now they're being traded
for eleven point two mil they've almost
doubled in price guys when the [__]
quest comes out there's gonna be so much
hype around this item again I thought of
this one instantly and going back to the
graph now I mean it's a no brainer
you're gonna be fighting a dragon I mean
just probably a boss fight this will be
the best in slot item probably so like
just sell your [__] house and rwt to
buy some DFS's and then sell them in
like two weeks alright now we're gonna
talk about the third item fell two pills
teleport this is the more uncommon one
now for this one I had to do some
digging guys basically all you got to
know what this item is when doing the
quest it is going to speed up is going
to speed up your quest by a bunch and
there's a shitty fairy ring that brings
you there no one's got time for [__]
fairy rings in 2000 and [__] 18 when
we've got these items that can teleport
us all around the game this one's gonna
be massive is you guys can see it's 3.3
K right now in old school that is very
wrong guys like look at this week graph
guys it was being traded for 2.4 K just
about one week ago and now it is just
climbing and it's going to pass 6 K so
yeah I'm surprised people caught on to
this playset on a stream or something
that's why I went up so you heard it
here now this is also a treasure trail
item so not that many are traded per
hour guys these things have the
potential to go up to like 20k each on
the day release of the quest again to
buy them at your own risk it's never too
late though because the quest is still
far away I'm talking like a month max of
course but you guys get the idea this is
a really good item to invest in alright
on to item number for something a little
more common dam in a potion we all know
what happens when new contact comes out
and people want to run around the game
trying to figure stuff out for hours on
end
Diamond potions are bought in mass bulk
on the day really when people don't have
quest sky do a bunch of running around
the game I mean right now stamina pots
for the quarter of the year are
an all-time low of around 5k this can
easily go back up to 5.5 K if you want a
safer investment stamina pots are
definitely something you should be
looking into I mean no one's got time
and trained [__] agility so you're
gonna buy these we all know it they're
gonna go up it's inevitable all right
and now wants to be last item this is
probably one of the biggest no-brainer
is just a Moroccan hosta didn't take
much research to realize this was gonna
be the best in sod to kill a boss it
probably will beats it it absolutely
[__] crushes dragons all the metallic
dragons are weak to crush and I mean
look at this in the dev blog guys
fighting the so-called
boss that'll be in the quest she's
wearing a goddamn hostile it can't be
more obvious than that this MRI capsid
is gonna increase in price and if you
don't believe it actually already has I
mean come on two weeks ago with seven
point three mil and now it's going for
almost a nine mil could easily rise
above 10 mil it's just probably the best
melee weapon to kill a boss with by far
and melee stats are the most common 99
so yeah samurai casts a pretty safe
investment am i pretty confident this is
gonna go up a lot of money and that's it
for the top five that I thought of guys
probably a lot more that I missed if you
guys think I missed key items be sure to
put them in the description I actually
might make a part 2 in like four days
from now I mean this quest is just
massive everyone remembers the first one
to kill requirements aren't terribly
high so a lot of people are going to be
able to do it and yeah that's pretty
much all I have to say about that now
what we're gonna do is talk about this
Dragon Slayer competition video if you
guys didn't already know the old-school
team is hosting a competition for the
best dragon slayer 60-second video
summary is a competition where you
basically send in a sixty second at
summary of the events and lore of the
original Dragon Slayer quest and you
have a chance to win a old-school gaming
PC which is pretty cool I can pretty
much already picture how I'd make my
video if you like some epic trailer
thing just summing up the last
Dragonslayer quests and then introducing
the new one at the very end I only have
until the 1st of January guys and then
the winner will be announced
three days after on Wednesday you guys
think I should make a minute video and
compete in this competition tell me what
you guys think I think I might actually
have a decent chance it is not a lot of
people are making videos I've gone on
YouTube I've seen a couple and they're
like like alright I think I can do
better
bi guys a lot of opportunities with this
new quest coming to the game so just
make sure you do your research before
you buy
any of these items all the graphs orangy
tracker I mean the graphs don't lie all
these items are actually rising I don't
own any of these items guys I'm not
flipping any of the items I discussed in
this video I'm just not patient enough
to hold on items for over like a week if
I'm gonna flip items it's gonna be
within a day or two so yeah don't worry
I'm not behind like a massive
pump-and-dump plan to trick you guys
into losing a lot of money just thought
it'd be an interesting video to make now
after looking at your comments guys
probably gonna make a part two because I
know I missed a lot of items yeah tell
me if you think I should enter the sixty
second competition video guide and until
next time